un po trovato nel convegno mai per non
si sognino storia oggi giocheremo un
continuo monga nella vita reale come
funziona dovremmo pescare il nostro
ruolo qua dal calderone dovremmo io
giallo vitale rosso e berlino cenette a
chi capiterà il ruolo di importanza per
cercare gli altri crew mentre li trova
dovrà eliminarli con una delle armi ogni
giorno l'impostore potrà scegliere che
arma utilizzare under che non dovranno
essere trovati dal l'impostore cosa
dovranno fare più mezzi dovranno
riportare l'allora target da chrome sv a
nella cameretta e rimetterla nel
calderone per riescono a riportare la
targhetta e rimetterla nel calderone
ritenta essere scoperti dall impostore
erano tal vivide siete pronti lasciato
beh mi piace perché se questo video
raggiunge i primi mila mi piace ci sarà
anche la seconda parte del nascondino
estremo di amalgama nella vita reale
mettetevi comodi prendete il popolo
viola ora pesca merlino il nostro
celeste anche se intento a rosicchiare
un giocattolo che eri berlino prendi ok
merlino sta pescando vediamo prenderlo
per lì lo prendo berlino ha preso
ora pesco io vediamo di dare numeri
avete 15 secondi per uscire da qua e
andare a nascondermi e poi io inizierò a
cercarmi
speriamo di vincere questo turno da
impostore che arma che abbiamo questo è
questo iniziamo a cercare i crew mail
vediamo se sono nascosti in giardino
[Musica]
guardate il rosso non so se nascosto da
sopra ma crede davvero che io non riesco
a vederlo di là andiamo subito fuori a
prenderlo e così qua fuori in giardino
rosso dovrebbe essere proprio lo sfratto
o no non c'è più definito
o fa è andato a nascondersi da qualche
altra parte
celeste
ma che fai e scaviamo via via via ieri
ecco qui il mio foglietto con la scritta
prudenza ve lo faccio vedere
eccolo qui non sto per mettere nel
calderone più bella che aveva vinto i
all'impostore al pratico è arrivato il
momento di pescara dal caldo air one
alcuni di come rosso ha perso perché
primo rosso da due vediamo urlino di
grosso dal vivo il pranzo scappare mi
raccomando dobbiamo trovare un bel
nasconto grazie per questi borsini
conviene scappare prima che vivrebbero
molto bene visto che siamo soli adesso
possiamo scegliere la nostra arma quale
scegliamo allora il national preso anita
quindi io penso di scendere a proprio
per classi
diamo il mio piano è questo aspetterò
che l'impostore esca dalla cameretta
una volta uscito mi intrufolo ero dentro
e proverò a metterli bigliettino dentro
al calderone così forse sarò salva
aspettiamo che esca via libera
ecco qua la mia targhetta mi basta
metterla dentro al calderone e afa rubin
nascondiamo ci siamo nel letto di sopra
insieme i pupazzi ma potrebbe vedermi
qua perché ho un casco enorme un'idea
c'è qualcosa di strano qui ho sentito
delle voci provenire da questa stanza
c'è nessuno qui c'è qualcosa di strano
qui andiamo a vedere meglio
i pupazzi mi sembrano tutti gli stessi
qui mi sembra che siano tutti al loro
stesso posto che pure con la sensazione
che ci sia un colore diverso qui niente
era solo una mosca ok ragazzi via libera
andiamo a mettere il nostro bigliettino
nel calderone biglietto mai cose per te
impostore ammette il biglietto nel
calderone c'è anche il biglietto
ricevette dopo la nostra no no berlino
non si mangia non si mangia grazie
ora salvo anche impostore
no noi crew mezzo abbiamo vinto
prossimo round pesca cellette questa
volta dai sembra che sta mangiando
vediamo cosa pescata ce n'è molto
difficile perché berlino fiuto
infallibile ci troverà subito rischiando
anche gli altri ruoli
grosso 6 un piano che andiamo a
nascondersi in giardino così celeste che
ha un fiuto infallibile non sentirà
subito il nostro odore morte possiamo
trovare qualcosa per ingannarlo tipo un
osso un ramo un'idea andiamo eccoci qua
in giardino o in mente un nascondiglio
perfetta guardate un po questo è un
tappeto di erba pinta mi nasconderò
sotto all'erba finta così merlino non mi
troverà perché sarò sottoterra
tecnicamente sotto all'erba almeno spero
che non mi trovi iniziamo a posizionarlo
eccolo qua guardate sembra proprio
l'airbus era secondo voi l'impostore
merlino mi troverà qua sotto dove si sta
nascondendo rosso adesso a quelle vanità
ok che cosa stai facendo e nascondendo
tutto questo tappeto detto a dire niente
a nessuno
ok allora femmina scooter insieme a
terra no no no no trovati il tuo
nascondiglio pelli non siamo di certo o
no per rigo sia arrivato da subito
trovare una scottiglia devo togliere il
casco altrimenti non ci sto qua sotto
e i rosso prendi il mio casco ok sono
mimetizzata bene malta bene direi bene
ottimo speriamo che non mi vedo bene
speriamo che quando eri un po di spazio
da un faro batti il tuo nascondiglio fi
o rosso mi deve sempre rubare i
nascondigli questo nascondiglio l'ho
inventato io
cosa si nasconde qua dietro album e
vorremmo nascondermi una scusa o no
trovato unito trovato
[Musica]
il suo nascondiglio non ha funzionato
tanto la celeste piace questo questo
solo scardigno ti ha scoperto noi hanno
perduto mid ohio spostare aperto guarda
e ride si mangia c'è qualcuno che
abbiamo dottore celeste berlino sia
trovato e ora per celeste
premetto premio berlino l'impostore è
felicissimo di aver vinto il suo premio
lasciate un mi piace per un nuovo
episodio di nascondino e ora rilassa un
po a quattro casalinghe su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video hd su
quella che preferite
buone visioni
[Applauso]
[Musica]